went to the particle Parsons in the
United States today you had a teacher a
painter Shawn Scully and again one of
the Catholics I wrote that his comment
down for you was I will obviously
possessed an extraordinary skill but
there was no struggle no true
observation and thus no heart do you
remember this comment of him I had to
remember what he's saying but the first
you cannot trust another artist
second you can I even trust some artists
drink alcohol all the time did you got
the diplomas at school no I'd never get
any diploma in any school I'm totally
clean that's why I can sit here you know
do you realize that you're now killing
the business model of this university
because it's based on the idea that
everybody should have a diploma
otherwise you cannot make a career but
you claim you can make a career without
diplomas I don't think I even have a
crazy idea
well you did something with your life
oh well we have to you know I think the
revolution should be yourself everyone
[Applause]
every day just just walk into different
direction and change your pardon of a
sinking habit or to something you never
did before cry why you want to laugh and
yeah you can you want tactics I can
teach you good
do you have an advice to aspiring young
artists people are now in their
teenagers or just 20s and multiple
common artists what what will be your
advice to them well my advice is to
forget about the art explain you should
do anything meaningful
you know challenges your mind but not to
talk about art or or think about arts
all the time
so then how will they become an artist
they don't have to become artists but if
they want to become an artist then they
will become a failure explain I don't
understand if you did go to museums just
save mango or Rembrandt how can they
become our good artists not possible why
not because those values being admitted
by society which already put it very
different colors and very different
meanings on those works so let's go back
how is it that you then became an artist
by I I did it by mistake no no I
I love mistakes it's a very successful
next slice
[Laughter]
you